337 personas condenadas a cadena
perpetua la justicia turca decidió
condenar a la mayoría de los 475
acusados del fallo de golpe de estado de
2016 a pasar el resto de su vida en la
cárcel entre los militares sentenciados
hay pilotos y altos cargos a los que
turquía señala por conspirar contra el
gobierno y apoyar una insurrección
orquestada por el antiguo aliado y ahora
opositor de tula gülen aunque los
familiares de los condenados lo niegan
fueron condenados de por vida a pesar de
no participar en el golpe a pesar de no
participar en ninguna actividad de esa
noche a pesar de luchar contra el golpe
encerrados en una habitación para evitar
ayudar a los golpistas a media noche
llevan cuatro años en prisión algunos
fueron torturados pero se quedaron
callados son muy jóvenes cuando los
metieron en la cárcel tenían 24 o 25
años ahora estarán encerrados de por
vida
la noche del 15 al 16 de julio de 2016
se produjeron enfrentamientos y
bombardeos en ankara entre oficialistas
y sublevados
de combates los golpistas se rindieron
aunque el saldo final de fallecidos en
la capital se elevó a 251 las familias
de las víctimas de aquella noche si
están satisfechas con la sentencia
creemos que se dieron los castigos
adecuados de acuerdo con las leyes
existentes
creemos que se ha hecho justicia
el estado no dejo a las familias de los
mártires ni a la sangre de los veteranos
en el suelo
desde el golpe fallido el presidente
turco recep tayip erdogán comenzó una
campaña de persecución a opositores que
junto a las reformas ha consolidado y
reforzado su poder en el país una
estrategia que ha sido duramente
criticada por sus ataques a la libertad